[Applause]
jeans
extra-hot nice Davises see the size
difference here
there's the double-team on ad and what
does McGee do we finished third in the
six-man voting season ago look at this
nice little pocket pass here through the
legs
great defense by the Lakers not only
doesn't he help in stunts but still
finds a way to block this shot on arrow
taking the challenge defensively
guarding the best perimeter player so
far three of five nine points got the
screen works in Ankara
[Applause]
they drove made a bid for him here goes
Beverly trying to work on the bigger
James kicks it out the dollar they swing
it over to Daniel's the fakin back
inside James to the track continues
Frank fit Daniels does the right thing
little high teardrop the contact what a
beautiful move the battle has begun
shot clock at three don't poke the fans
[Applause]
20 points
[Applause]
I'm stirring for the winter is coming
from Davis the shifty Williams optimal
[Applause]
to go for the tooth better with his
third think about the degree of
difficulty on this shot going left
but shooting back right got the mismatch
down low you want it
LeBron triple team here comes come hard
you know that's a lot of communication
out on the floor and some thought was
out of bounds
shot clock down to eight please send
into the strike a pretty three this was
supposed to be a switch but no one
communicated to Beverly so he was
closing out to Danny Green Rivers has
done bringing that championship
experience from from Boston it has
changed a little bit but the Clippers in
the playoff
four quick points off the bench turnover
picked up by Williams here comes Hammond
[Applause]
retrieve I'm hopeless an amazing block
and don't feel bad chairman I've been in
this same situations in the here on 333
rest here in this third and probably be
able to play the hole for who comes
parachuting out of the rafters domine
and take over games offensively
[Applause]
lock here by Leonard Kauai 9:15
[Applause]
just plop right over
that's a to and hero hits it to go and
13 off the bench for handful dribbles
here as Dudley is going down
juh michael green is watching Davis in
the corner wide open montrezl harrell
lost his shoe 9 2010 in Cleveland and
against him
Green got the bounce never rebound for
Beverly he's got nine of them
[Applause]
he's been dealing with an assortment of
various injuries tweaked his knee the
other night
he's also has the shoulder problem
George drives black comedy teams to be
legitimate championship contenders Paul
George beautiful pass seven points in
three minutes for Kyle Kuzma Kawhi
Leonard answers right back with his
second three-pointer he's been an elite
rebounder he's not quite the defender he
once was but still good that's not gonna
happen
Rondo meanwhile he's shooting 41% from
three this year nice feed inside
Williams a montrezl harrell have a
special connection out on the floor
making life difficult for him on the
offensive end
buckless the steal but a sensational
block this is winning basketball get
asking your guys to compete on every
play a tremendous recovery just a few
free throws in the point total and
neither David nor James in the game
couponer a goaltend there are clipper
talked about how you can get the wrong
impression of play is coaching against
them and he said I was absolutely wrong
about Lulu no it's some English off the
class on a nice feed from Anthony Davis
taken away by Danny Green his former
Raptor teammate Kuzma gets inside
blocked by Jorge knocks it off the
backboard and Patterson will have a dunk
down the other end
Paul George Anthony Davis fakes now
drives gets inside George makes this
move goes right at Davis Davis Davis
cuts it again
James who's before three
hold our guys before this game that the
team that wins is the team that comes
out with the right purpose they had the
right purpose in that so that's five
blocks shots from again my speed inside
zoom BOTS the finish beautiful pass
service but the shot fake the roll the
pocket pass this beautiful to man they
have a a number of guys that are wing
defenders and Dwight Howard off the
bench as well or fuckless on the steel
mark list gets in something get it back
in the Davises hands with Beverly Garlin
him look at that handle but stripped by
Leonard Leonard drives inside back to
Sioux did it win in but I'm about to
drop off path Kawhi Leonard realizing
that LeBron James couldn't foul and once
help comes drops off the beautiful time
Zuba does the rest
timeout lead it's cut to seven here on
the third right now a seven-point game
Paul George banks at home as the shot
clock expired
McGee blocked by heartless but James
right there on the follow shot clock
turned off
Lakers who do not have a fala gate of
Williams green shaman / three putts it
in when a Clippers tie the game now
scored the Lakers 2717 in the fourth
quarter Harrell gets free as Lou
Williams you see a cheeks when I see you
[Applause]
defensive play turns into potential
three-point plays dwight howard having
little UCLA cut Kuzma misses off a good
block and when Harold rotates over Lou
Williams has to pull in to Dwight Howard
I love that flip shot by Harrell every
undersides big needs a Caruso
caldwell-pope Howard and Kuzma for bench
players out there now for the Lakers
with James shot clock at seven George
nice feed inside
montrezl harrell George puts pressure on
Dwight Howard and forces that turtle and
as you say that mark rajon rondo gets
off the bench most likely for one of the
biggest Leonard playing this one and
Leonard with 31
James Davis sketches
there's Patrick Beverley off the glass
Batson all
[Applause]
families deflected by Davis Davis comes
away with it and throws it down a little
bit of a footrace it was able to get
past Morris the percentage goes up a
little bit and he was on fire when he
was with the Knicks earlier this season
James took a hard hit thanks at home and
a chance for a three-point play so they
can attack early in the clock
James just wipes
montrezl Harrel has come on for the
Clippers well the best bench in the NBA
George nice hesitation he got hit and
he'll go to the line for the three-point
play and at Maya LeBron James Guilin and
Anthony Davis but I have every right to
feel like I can very well be the best
player on a given night you have to have
a guy who's willing to be a glue
connector type of guy and still be great
pass inside James to Davis that's some
sweet team basketball there what a play
by LeBron I mean he knew Leonard was
rotating before the ball hit his hand
and that ability to touch it to Davis is
special
Williams against Kuzma will shake and
bake up and under off the glass sweet
Rondo looking for LeBron James deflected
by Paul George and here's to Michael
Green who should have it easy to Dwight
Howard the rebound slapped out of his
hands
Reggie Jackson comes up with the loose
ball goes inside reverse blocked by
James but right to Zhu Michael Green who
misses and Kuzma another rebound trying
to use the rim as protection but James
was gonna get it on eat but first look
to push Lou Williams again this time
able of finished Lou Williams old
reliable on the offensive end the
ability to score comfortable this is the
largest lead we were the first half
James draws the foul the strength again
and one Wow against the strength and
length of Leonard his sight of Anthony
Davis
off the turnover James throws it up the
D Oh knock down a path of some BOTS
blocked it beautifully sue blocks on the
follow and a Clippers regain the lead
James the offensive board cross-court to
Bradley Avery Bradley
the no-look pass you think he's going to
Anthony Davis he waits until Avery
Bradley gets to his spot on point pass
stepping rhythm tell you what the Lakers
hit fighting Jeff he's driving me a
little crazy right now today he throws
the ball at his feet he's got to be
penalized and I don't care how nice the
guy is this is a technical foul how
about the other two Paul George with the
three quarter
little hand back right into the
three-point shot
big-time skill into a three-point shot
Bradley short that time Lou Williams
racing up the floor finds George steps
back another three got it
Paul George lighting it up but he forces
the Lakers to Cole time flying out of
down the floor in transition gets the
wide open three entirely sit back Rose
getting that their playoff lost voice
sound as LeBron James hits the three
the Lakers go up by seven on Leonard
didn't go for the fake Joe Michael Green
gets inside beautiful feet and montrezl
harrell once again finishes broad team's
offense Lee's shooting free throws to
western ray get out my way I'm making
plays James goes right at green right on
the follow this Markieff Morris the
crash the offensive board it should be
called a different type of assistant
because it certainly is good find by Lou
Williams
terrific finish by caldwell-pope oh nice
floater over the outstretched fingertips
of the defender drives hop-step
in the paint to Davis for the slam
terrific pass Rev LeBron James for his
ninth assist what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content